Narrator: A lot of
people aren't comfortable
swimming in open water.
I mean, you never know what lives
in the water beneath your feet.
The ocean holds many
bizarre deep sea monsters.
As you dive 140 meters underwater,
you might see a megamouth shark.
Sure, they look scary, but those 50 rows
of teeth are for filtering krill.
The Japanese spider crab is happy
to welcome you 300 meters down.
These massive crustaceans are thought
to live to 100 years old
and are a Japanese delicacy.
The frilled shark looks closer to an eel.
Its needle-like teeth hook
squid one half its size
and its jaws can gulp them down.
Even deeper is the Pacific blackdragon.
It uses its chin barbel as a
lure to attract small fish.
Another 150 meters down,
we meet the vampire squid.
It has bioluminescent
organs called photophores
that produce flashes of light.
But it doesn't drink blood.
It prefers free-floating
debris from the surface.
The deeper you go the
more alien things look.
Goblin sharks are believed
to be unchanged for 25 million years,
basically making them living fossils.
They can launch their
jaws forward to grab prey.
Look, here comes the blobfish!
This thrilling deep-sea fish
was voted the world's ugliest animal
by the Ugly Animal Preservation Society.
But its jelly-like skin looks
much more natural at 900 meters.
Down here, we enter the midnight zone
where no natural light can reach.
You might also pass the
Tiburonia granrojo, or big red,
one of the largest jellyfish in the world.
The fangtooth has teeth to spare,
the largest of any fish.
It can't even fully close its mouth.
The barreleye looks upward
through its translucent head.
It recognizes the silhouette of its prey
in even the most dim light.
But it should watch out
below for the ghost shark.
Its body is covered with sensory organs
that detect motion in
the surrounding water.
Deeper down are giant isopods,
supersized crustaceans.
These guys are closely
related to common pill bugs.
Down at 2200 meters is one
of the biggest residents of the deep.
At 14 meters long, the colossal squid
is the largest known invertebrate.
Its arms have sharp hooks,
which it uses to catch prey
and fight sperm whales.
As we go even deeper,
we enter the hadal zone,
where life is less common.
The sea devil is the
quintessential deep-sea anglerfish.
Its bioluminescent lure attracts prey
close to its massive jaws.
But you can still find
some extreme life forms
as deep as 7,000 meters under the surface.
Like our friend, the sea spider.
It sucks up worms from the
ocean floor with its proboscis.
There are potentially thousands more
undiscovered creatures
swimming around underneath us.
Who knows what else might
be living down there.